الله اكبر
نحن لا نخشى روسيا وعليها ان تخشانا هكذا
صرخت فنلندا وعلى حين غفله القلم الفنلندي
يوقع ليحقق اسرع انضمام
بتدابير جوابيه فوريه وفاكنر تحضر هديه
الربيع لبوتين من اوكرانيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي سنعاملكم بطريقه قاسيه
من الان وصاعدا وشرط وحيد امام انضمام
اوكرانيا للنيتو فما هو المنطاد الصيني لم
يذهب عبثا ووصل لهدفه والولايات المتحده
ترد على الصين عسكريا وبكين تتوعد بالرد
بينما اردوغان يهدد بتلقين امريكا درسا لن
تنساه والرجل الاصفر يدخل التاريخ والامن
الامريكي يتاهب واليمن يقترب من السلام
الدائم
روسيا ترد على النيتو عسكريا الحرب تخرج
عن طورها وتاخذ منحا اخر حلف النيتو يشعل
النار ولا يطفئها ومواجهه الحلف مع روسيا
تقترب والعالم يضع يديه على صدره ها هي
فنلندا تتخلى عن عقود من عدم الانحياز
العسكري لتقرر الانضمام الى حلف النيتو
حتى انها اعلنت عن استثمارات عسكريه كبرى
منذ بدء حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
على ضفته الشماليه الشرقيه ولكن ما هو اهم
من ذلك وان فنلندا تمتلك حدودا مشتركه
بطول
1340 كيلو مترا مع روسيا كما تملك واحدا
من اقوى الترسانات من قطع مدفعيه في
اوروبا وبمجرد انضمام فنلندا الى الحلف
تضاعفت حدود النت مع روسيا اكثر من الضعف
لتصل الى حوالي
2500 كيلو متر ليصبح انضمام فنلندا الى
النيتو اسرع انضمام لدوله جديده الى الخلف
على الاطلاق هنا الفرحه لم تسع رئيس
فنلندا لينفخ صدره ويصرح قائلا وروسيا
تهدد دائما ونحن لا نخشاها وعلى موسكو ان
تخشى دول الجوار
ما تخف علينا يا محمد رمضان موسكو بدورها
لم تقف ساكنه مؤكده سفيرها في قرر موسكو
نقل الاسلحه النوويه الى بيلاروسيا
وطائرات التي تحمل اسلحه نوويه ستحط في
الاراضي البيلاروسيه ما يجعلها على عتاب
النيتو والصراع يوشك ان يندلع بين الطرفين
فعن اي صراع نتحدث يا ساده ليصب امين عام
حلف الناتو
الزيت على النار بقوله انضمام فنلندا
للحلف يعزز جاهزيته في شرق اوروبا لمنع
روسيا من شن اي هجمات جديده ضد جيرانها
لدى فنلندا قوات وقدرات عسكريه مهمه يمكن
ان تقدمها لحلف النيتو لافتا الى انها
ستحصل على ضمانات من النيتو للدفاع عن
امنها فهل هي ضمانات كالتي قدمتموها
لاوكرانيا من قبل هذا الرد الروسي يطبخ
على نار هادئه حيث اعلن نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
العسكري على المحورين الغربي والشمالي
الغربي ردا على انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو
واكد ان موسكو بدات بالفعل في تطوير
تدابير جوابيه لوقف التهديدات المحتمله ما
يتعلق بانضمام فنلندا الى حلف النيتو وذلك
وفقا لوكاله
يعبر عن فرحته بانضمام فنلندا بقوله ان
باب الحلف مفتوح امام اي دوله ديمقراطيه
ترغب في الانضمام له لكن لا تتسرع هذا
فروسيا لم تقل كلمتها بعد يقولها وعلى
لسان متحدثه
لحلف النيتو تفاقم اخر للوضع حيث ان توسيع
الحلف يعد تعديا على امن روسيا لكن النيتو
لا يعير اهتماما للتحذيرات الروسيه ليعلن
الامين العام للحلفا قضيه عضويه اوكرانيا
في النيتو ستتم ولكن بشرط واحد وهو ان
تكسب صراعها مع روسيا هذا الشرط اقرب
للمستحيل وفق الاوضاع الحاليه فهل من شرط
اخر يا هؤلاء وهنا يتم تاجيج الصراع اكثر
فاكثر حيث يعقد وزراء خارجيه نيت اجتماعا
لمناقشه ملف نشر روسيا رؤوسا نوويه قرب
حدود دول البلطيق لياتي الرد من وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجينا الذي قال الاتحاد
الاوروبي اصبح معاديا وخسر موسكو مضيفا ان
بلاده ستتعامل بطريقه قاسيه مع اوروبا اذا
لزم الامر بحسب موقع ارجونتي ومن تبادل
التصريحات الى تراشق الطائرات والمدافع
حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه تصفيه اكثر من
400 مقاتل اوكراني وتدمير مستودعات
الذخيره واسقاط ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه في
كافه المحاور وعلى الطرف الاخر اعلنت
قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها
اسقطت اربع عشره مسيره ايرانيه من طراز
شاهد من بين 17 المسيره اطلقتها القوات
الروسيه في جنوبي اوكرانيا ومنطقه اوديسا
وبين هذا وذاك مفاتيح باخموت قد تصبح هديه
الربيع للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين هنا
رئيس مجموعه
يقول ان قواته رفعت العلم الروسي فوق مبنى
اداره مدينه باخموت في شرق اوكرانيا مضيفا
انه من وجهه نظر قانونيه تم الاستيلاء على
باخموت وان كان الجيش الاوكراني لا يزال
يتمركز في الاجزاء الغربيه
بكين تضرب واشنطن في مقتل
خططهم تؤتي ثمارها واسلحتهم تصيب اهدافها
نعم فاصحاب العيون الضيقه لا يمزحون وهنا
تعلنها الشبكه ام بي سي الامريكيه قائله
ان المنطاد الصيني الذي اسقطته الولايات
المتحده في بدايه شهر فبراير الماضي جمع
معلومات استخباراتيه من مواقع عسكريه
امريكيه حساسه رغم جهد امريكا لمنعه من
ذلك لتضيف الشبكه ان معظم المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه التي جمعت الصين كانت من
اشارات الكترونيه ولم تكن عبر التقاط صور
وهذا يعني ان الصين حققت هدفها
الاستخباراتي بنجاح اي انه بهذه الطريقه
او بتلك وصلت
[موسيقى]
واشنطن المنطاد او لم تسقطها فهي لا بؤسكم
يا ابناء العمسات لكن الامريكان يحظون
بفرصه للرد هذه المره ففي خطوه جديده على
الطريق مواجهه الصين اعلنت رئاسه الفلبين
من حال الولايات المتحده اربعه مواقع
اضافيه لانشاء قواعد عسكريه احداها قريبه
من بحر الصين الجنوبي واخرى على مقربه من
تايوان ليكون بذلك عدد القواعد الامريكيه
في الفلبين تسع قواعد
كما يتم التفاوض بشان قاعده امريكيه عشره
محتمله الخارجيه الصينيه واخذت على عاتقها
مهمه الرد على هذه الخطوه الامريكيه وقالت
ان اقامه قواعد عسكريه جديده
بالفلبين سيؤدي لمزيد من التصعيد
الرجل الاصفر يربك امريكا في الداخل
والخارج ما عادت امريكا تجد راحتها وامنها
السابقين فالخارج يجمع التحالفات
لمعاداتها والداخل يعج بالفوضى وهو دونالد
ترامب يدخل تاريخ كاول رئيس امريكي سابق
يواجه اتهامات جنائيه ليجلس اليوم امام
القاضي في قاعه محكمه منعت بمدينه نيويورك
بعد ان سلم نفسه وسط استنفار امني مشدد
وتاهب كامل من الشرطه تحسبا لاي طارئ في
منهجزا من قبل السلطات حيث تم اخذ بصماته
قبل مثوله امام القاضي يقول البيت الابيض
انه لا تعليق لديه على القضيه وانه مستعد
لاي تهديد بشان الاضطرابات والفوضى
المحتمله في محاكمه ترامب اما ترامب
فقالها للعلن لست مذنبا لينفي ارتكابه
جنائيه تتعلق بتزوير سجلات الاعمال فهل
تدخل هذه القضيه الولايات المتحده في نفق
مظلم الاحداث والتطورات قال الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان انه لن يستقبل السفير
الامريكيه لدى انقره بعد ان اجتمع الاخير
بزعيم معارضه كمال جليك قبل اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه باسابيع واضاف
اردوغان في الانتخابات القادمه علينا
تلقين الولايات المتحده درسا اكد الامين
العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي جاسم البداوي
ان الظروف الحاليه مواطيه للانخراط في
محادثات السلام للتوصل الى حل سياسي في
اليمن فهل سيتحقق السلام ليعود اليمن
السعيد سعيدا كما كان النيت يتوسع وروسيا
تتحضر نوويا فماذا بعد كل هذه التوترات يا
هؤلاء
[موسيقى]